voici l'histoire d'un petit fruit rouge
plus connu sous le nom de goyavier de
chine originaire de chine n'en entendons
du brésil il s'est vite développée dans
les pays au climat chaud et humide
à la réunion on le connaît sous le nom
de goyavier un fruit sucré de couleur
rouge brillante
il est tellement apprécié qu on le
déguste nature en gelée en sirop en
confiture en anglais sans coller un
gâteau en poche ce petit arbuste c'est
tellement bien installé à la réunion qui
l'a rapidement colonisé les bas et les
forêts humides des eaux de l'île
devenant une espèce invasive
explications
une espèce invasive ou envahissante est
une espèce qui a été introduite par
l'homme ou par les animaux dans un
nouvel environnement naturel et le
développement de cette plante est
tellement important qu'ils menacent les
autres végétaux déjà présents sur ce
milieu notamment les espèces endémiques
une plante endémique est une plante que
l'on ne retrouve que sur un territoire
spécifique et nulle part ailleurs au
monde
par exemple à la réunion il existe près
de 250 espèces endémiques comme le en
bas ville le fleur jaune
le café bourbon pointu
on connaissait les qualités du fruit
mais il y a quelques années de cela un
petit groupe de personnes s'est
intéressé au bois de goyavier assez
longue tige danse est pourtant très
souple en décembre 2011 portée par le
conseil départemental et créer le
premier atelier de transformation du
bois de goyavier c'est au coeur de ces
forêts que des agents coupe le bois de
goyavier une récolte qui se fait tout au
long de l'année sur des espaces définis
par l'office national des forêts donc
c'est un double intérêt de faire cette
coupe donc ça a tout d'abord fait permet
de créer une activité pour l'équipe qui
vient justement travailler ici c'est ça
leur permet de couper du goyavier et
ensuite cette coupe ça permet une
régénération naturelle des espèces qui
sont propres à la réunion donc on
retrouvera toutes les espèces endémiques
de la réunion qui pourront repousser les
brement sur ces parcelles qui ont été
désinfectés environ une fois coupé les
branches sont regroupés et transporté à
l'atelier de transformation qui se
trouve au chaudron
c'est ici qu'une quarantaine de
personnes travaillent le bois de
goyavier selon une méthode bien précises
la première étape de transformation
c'est l'étuvage c'est un grand bac on
met de l'eau à bouillir et on met le
bois
dans dans les tubes ça permet de rendre
le bois très souple pour le travail et
affi
à
oh
la deuxième étape de transformation le
bois est sortie de l'étude
il a été chauffée on le passe dans
l'ordre soir afin d'avoir une gaule est
bien droite 1 pour la transformation
suivante
à
oh
la troisième étape de transformation
c'est l'usinage le bois il arrive dans
cette pièce à l'aide de différentes
machines on va le pont c'est le coupé le
redresser le ciller le raboter afin
d'avoir des pièces qui nous serviront à
la fabrication des objets artisanaux
et une fois cette transformation opérée
le bois de goyavier est prêt à être
assemblés
pouvait voir dans cette salle une grande
partie des objets artisanaux réalisés à
partir de ce bois et bien plus encore
ah ah
voilà les enfants nous sommes allés en
forêt pour découvrir la collecte du bois
de goyavier puis nous sommes allés à
l'atelier de production pour voir la
transformation de la matière
non nous sommes à l'espace règle et où
nous pouvons découvrir les objets
réalisés par la filiale goyavier comme
la chaise pliante la petite chaise
spécialement pour les plus petits la
table en bois de goyavier et de paniers